this is beyond mere earthly realm
another Ice King episode they don't know
it's gonna be Ice King I like that I
like it when he just comes out of
nowhere this is where they come across
this lamb it looks like a lamb cake and
and Finn touches ink gets sucked into
this other world
kinda like my Frodo puts on the ring of
lore the Rings nobody can see him or
hear him he's in like some sort of
spirit world and you should figure out
how to get out but the ice game is only
one who can see in a man Hyrum so the
Ice King has have given up all the
spirits in his house and then he thinks
that he'll be his friend afterwards but
he reveals his plan Finn says he's just
going to whatever go back to the hole
that he took all the spirit savvy so I
go wait I'll help you get back to like
when it's falling apart yeah so he
changes his plan to go and break the
lamp cake so that they can get out or he
could get out but the Ice King
accidentally touched you say he gets
sucked in and they use their spirity
powers to move stuff around break the
thing and they laugh um it was cute I
mean it was but I love anything we go
into another world and it's like house
is gonna look in in this other world of
you know it's like it's very similar but
just a little off or as different
creatures and stuff like him solid I
love the light world in the dark world
and stuff where it's like you know it's
like this couch would still here be here
but maybe you know the world it'd have a
mouth or something I don't know
something really good so that's the most
imagine if I could get for the moment
that this show kind of sucks out your
mind sometimes because it's so strange
and yeah I mean it was fun I like like I
said no than worldliness and the big
laugh I got is when Ice King sees him I
just love that reveal they seize the
leaf any is I kind of leaf princess
things like it's just a leaf you dummy
it's like I know but it's mine
and I just love that little beat that
wait a second I like it when somebody
acknowledges that they see them even
though it sort of takes a minute
you know they're quick um I'm trying to
think it's not all I got on this no you
know the spirits were pretty cool
looking - I like the design of these
spirits I love anything that gets fed
those nice surreal layout so it's not
all I got yeah it was cute I liked it um
the thing that sticks out to me I don't
know if you notice Finn calls him Simon
yeah he goes at some point it's like
whoa that was kind of cool that sort of
threw me and then I realized oh yeah I
guess that is his name yeah and I
thought that was kind of cool I don't
know if he's acknowledging him as uh I
mean I don't know I guess like if Finn
is calling him Simon he's acknowledging
not only this story but that he is a
separate person he's not just like that
dumb Ice King but like he doesn't I
mean he's a person and I don't know I
thought it was pretty cool um I don't
know I guess the only other thing I can
say about it is you know it kind of
teaches going back to you what does it
teach the kids although not much no but
if you think about it you know that
whole like idea of if you present
yourself a certain way you know be
careful how you present yourself like
the Ice King has already have has this
reputation you know of being a jerk that
comes in and ruins everything so he's
coming to break the lamb because he's
gonna save Finn but Jake's first
reaction doesn't kick the hell out of
here I don't think so I'm gonna beat
your ass because you're here and clearly
you always cause trouble and you never
do nice things it's also how I entered
the room does that turn like this guy
maybe if you like way to the door
knocked out and said I know that Finn is
trapped in the lamb I can help you Jacob
lady oh it's - busting her windows olam
oh but Jake doesn't always do the right
things that's okay Jake causes a lot of
problems as a matter of fact I still
think that it's Jake's damn fault that
Goliad turned crazy evil
oMG and I mean one thing before I forget
I like the ice king seeing through the
TV like what am i watching it's just was
it doctor whatever I like that I thought
that was you know cute this is it well
if you go back to the one where uh uh oh
my god bubble gum got busted and then
possessed by the Lich and all that stuff
Ice King already brought the fact that
he sees things with his wizard eyes yeah
he doesn't know what's there and what's
not there and they already show some of
those creatures at that point in time so
I like how they actually have gone back
to it and said no he actually does see
this all the time actually I like that
you bring that up because I kind of
forgot until you mentioned that but I'd
now I remember when he first said that
before with I see things with my wizard
eyes I remember thinking like oh ha ha
that's you know cuz he's cuckoo bird
yeah he sees things and yes this would
so you know actually does see these
things that are actually going on I love
the fact that where the lamb was found
is a direct connection to the pits in
the ice king's castle
yeah it's like almost like this unending
loop I was wondering that was gonna
connect back to anything maybe a lot
another episode I don't know but I'd
sort of like I thought that's
interesting to like yeah why interesting
points like oh wait a minute oh well and
he goes back you know I do also like the
or what I was actually expecting was the
poops I'll comb the poop ones the ones
puking the little it looks more like
pooping than puking I thought when I
first saw this that somehow it would
pull back a revealer show it from the
real-world perspective that those were
gone ters or dunkers all that big a
funny here's them yeah there's like a
little penguin
that's where they all came from and
they're crawling all over the asking
like you know like they would and I'm
like that would be hilarious and it
would pull back but they never do so let
her know but else will love always like
oh I love Carly got me I can't even
touch him and then later on he's like oh
my god they're touching me for real
rolls off the screen no that was pretty
funny I know I liked it I thought it was
fun I loved the lamb I think I actually
sold a normal like an actual life-sized
lamb with fins face on there I would
actually buy that I mean they hit there
that's only make a few probably because
I don't have enough Eve like we get it
but like the people that wit get it
would be like yeah I'm buying up
whatever price of cost I'll buy it
those because it's it's just a sheep
with bin space just be like oh that's
cool that's definitely conversation
starter 101 I guess what I really liked
about this episode I mean for the most
part yeah you can kind of look at it
it's kind of bland or there's not ton
going on but for me again it reinforces
that the Ice King isn't just bonkers
like Eeyore as you say cuckoo bird you
know you know he's actually seeing all
this crazy at all times and he
can't touch anything you can't do it he
can't take a broom and try to sweep them
away he's consistently surrounded by
these things that are flying around
looking weird watching him in the
bathroom crawling on him and he can't do
anything about it
that would make anyone a little crazy
well granted if he is also like you said
just like he'll make some of that stuff
up to he says oh yeah I have the
invisible Finny right yeah but he's
really yeah no I agree like he's gone
like off the deep end and you know going
back to the crown and all of that stuff
I like that they're kind of reinforcing
that yes it's there he's not just crazy
ya know I like that stuff when you'd
think they're always not sad it's like
oh wow no reality is actually stranger
then you know what they thought was
fiction so
no I definitely like it huh so um gotcha
hmm yeah looms
right now is that a hunter or Gunther
booter of Gundy Oh work Wow - pretty
good